[Applaudissements]
monter le moral
regarde les gens qui s'est dit mais le
plus c'est que si la femme idéale et à
tamesna ce que nous avons envie de nous
et avec caroline a tout de suite
franchement c'est vrai pour c'est que ça
la femme de votre vie c'est la femme
idéale elle est sublime elle est jolie
intelligente elle adore
le site
[Applaudissements]
bien aussi
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu jean
michel et il s'est encore vif il élit
bonifié comme du bon vin ça va bien
vaccaro de felipe massa chez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
oui
et de tout ce qu'on s'est dit et oui car
hausse était bon c'était fort c'était
pure avec les grands shows que tu est
choqué ce n'est pas de ce baiser quand
même fou mais j'avais cru comprendre
qu'elle est et rhin non non oui en vrai
j'ai toujours dit oui le premier jour
ici à tpm paix que je trouvais que
j'emmenais était très très beau et
complètement mon style dans l'absolu
dans l'idéal moi c'est un pierre arditi
mélangé à je sais pas il déclare me fait
un peu italien et il est chic il est
sympa à brett et le style de tout le
monde mette à personne
[Applaudissements]
les personnes devant vous c'est
incroyable
ouais je vous le dis il ya quelques
jours un élément apparemment il venu
changer le cours de l'existence ton de
cette table regardez vous nous dire
après si c'est du lard ou du khallouf
onat la chaude et rauque ouverte
donnez vos coordonnées au toit alors
donc à vous passer
je suis là
quoi c'est fini nouveau ton mac c'est
fini
enfin ces photos pour finir d un petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lahlou tao avant nous dire bien sûr si
c'est dur la roue du khallouf
on va faire ce qu'on appelle le test de
compatibilité mais demandé à caroline et
jean michel de bien vouloir me rejoindre
au centre de ce plateau et après bien
sûr caroline tu nous diras tout comme la
wii je vous dirai toujours hâte au maire
de levallois si c'est forcément tous
deux heureux j'ambitionne s'est fait
descendre des casques tracer leur buteur
alors vous voyez que ces manuels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez mettre ces casques et vous
allez danser collé serré puisque ces
casques sont reliés directement à la
love machine très mignon qui va analyser
tous vos comportements attention s'agit
d'un test de compatibilité
je les trouvais dans mon film préféré
des sous doués en vacances assure
s'évitera semaine prochaine mardi soir
là les seuls car on est tous les styles
montrez à céder sans demander pourquoi
toi et moi
dessiner inutile fui ou de lutter
bref c'était dans l'autre sur des styles
et
tu ne pourra pas y échapper
c'est gravé dans la vie
le v
je suis
[Musique]
attention vous avez dansé
connaissiez-vous d'avoir tout de suite
les gars et je vous le dis c'est
extrêmement et je dis bien tomber
vraiment fiable l'avez vous le dis si si
si je vous le dis il dit je vais tester
cet après-midi et votre chien je les ai
testés peux pas vous dire avec qui vous
pouvez pas non plus tout savoir chier
c'est qu'ubs avoir tout de suite non non
on va voir tout de suite votre
compatibilité alors regardez le maximal
attention
jean-michel caroline mais s'il vous
plaît on peut savoir comment alors
jean-michel votre coeur est rempli donc
vous êtes à 100%
malheureusement carreaux afin de les
rendre un gars c'est joliment dit tarek
tu sors d'europe tout le monde a vu
c'est tout ça c'est une nouvelle porte
donc gens mais aussi pour les haines
surprise mais les premiers rails là
rowling est ce que vous êtes en ce
moment où toujours pas ma toujours pas
même pas ce soir jean michel a par
avance fait pas de la saint valentin
vous n'avez pas les la passe et seule
une dernière chance tout à l'heure à
huawei merci faites vous quand même un
petit bisou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore
je veux laisser rêver non non c'est bon